[MUSIC PLAYING]
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Hi, folks.
How's it going?
Congratulations, it's Friday.
You made it.
Ah.
It's been a really
fun couple of days.
I know it's been
fun for me getting
to talk to a lot of customers,
see a lot of product
announcements, a lot of demos, a
lot of fantastic conversations.
And I'm really excited, today,
to come talk about App Engine.
We've got a lot of good
stuff going on here.
We're going to be going
through a couple of cool things
you can do with App Engine.
Really, this is a product that's
been around for 10 years now,
which, in the cloud space, is
a really, really long time.
And from when it first came
out to where we are now,
a lot of things have happened.
The cloud has changed.
Technology has changed.
The kinds of
applications that we
need to build for our customers
have fundamentally changed.
And really, what today about
is digging in and understanding
how App Engine has kind
of changed with the times
to make it a great
platform for helping
build your applications.
So let's have a
little bit of fun.
Before we get into fun, a
little bit about myself.
My name is Justin Beckwith.
I'm a product manager
at Google primarily,
these days, actually
working on App Engine.
So this is kind of--
for the last few years,
this has been my baby.
It's very exciting.
If you want to get
in touch with me,
my Twitter information is up
there, also, my GitHub handle.
All of the demos that
we're going to see today,
and actually, a lot
of the technology
that we're going to see
today, it's all open source.
And this is all part
of one of the things
that we're trying to do, which
is get more and more openness,
more into the open
source community.
And everything you're going to
see here, large parts of it,
all open source.
So before we degrade in,
just a little bit-- before we
go build demos on App Engine
and learn a bunch of cool stuff,
what is App Engine?
At the end of the day,
it's a very simple way
to take your code,
give it to us,
and run it on top of Google's
infrastructure at scale.
So really, the fundamental thing
that we want you to walk away
with is, you bring your code,
and we handle running it
on Google's infrastructure.
And when you're running it on
Google's infrastructure, what
you're really doing
is running it inside
of a data center
that's been proven out
for almost the last 20 years,
the same technology that's
been built for Google
Search, Maps, Gmail.
All these things that
we rely on day in
and day out, we have proven
infrastructure that's
gotten the job done for us
at Google and proven methods
for getting it done.
And we think we
want to make it easy
for you to do the same
thing with App Engine.
So what would you build
on top of App Engine?
Well, there are a
couple of sweet spots.
And we've seen that several
Compute offerings today,
and we're going to get
into those in a little bit.
But really, the sweet
spot for App Engine
is web applications and APIs.
So if you're building
a user-facing website,
be it in Node.js, Ruby, PHP--
you know, any of your
traditional web languages--
it's really a great destination.
Because you can just
build it, deploy it,
and run it without having to
think about the ops or scale.
It's also become
really popular back end
for mobile applications.
There are some pretty
canonical examples out there,
folks like Snapchat, other
gaming companies that
are built on top of us.
It's really easy to scale
up very, very quickly
on App Engine.
And it's easy to get up
and running very fast.
So it's been a popular
choice for mobile back ends.
With that really comes
just, also, HTTP APIs.
Even if it's not a traditional
mobile back end, a lot of us,
our applications
are powered by APIs.
And App Engine integrates really
nicely with Cloud Endpoints,
another product
that we announced
a v2 of recently, which
makes it easy to do things
like metering, billing, logging,
authentication, all sitting
on top of your API.
And Cloud Functions
and App Engine
make a really nice
fit together to go
build those kinds of things.
And then lastly,
it's a great fit
for line of business
applications.
We're working with a
lot of enterprises today
that have a ton
of internal sites
that they need to build
quickly, maintain, and do it
with a small staff
that they don't want
to have to build up expertise
in five different deployment
systems.
And App Engine has been
a great fit for that.
As a matter of fact,
it's running the majority
of a lot of our
internal apps that we
have at Google,
the user-facing web
applications we use for a
lot of our payroll systems,
for our learning and
management systems.
All of this stuff at Google
is actually increasingly built
on top of App
Engine, and we think
it's great for other
companies to do that as well.
So where does App Engine
fit into the broader context
of Compute?
You know, we've heard
a lot of announcements.
We saw the Cloud
Functions announcement.
We have committed use
discounts on virtual machines.
We've heard containers,
containers, containers
and Kubernetes over
and over again.
Where does App
Engine fit into this?
And when is it a
good choice to use?
So we'll start at the
bottom of the pyramid.
When we think about
virtual machines
and we think about
Compute Engine, really,
what you're running
is infrastructure.
So if you're an organization
that's picking up,
and you're moving something,
a bunch of applications that
were built on traditional
virtual machines,
and you want to pick that up
and find a path to the cloud,
usually, this is the
easiest first step
that you can take to
get into the cloud.
If you want to think
about infrastructure,
you want to think about VMs, you
want to think about networks,
then this is a good fit.
One level up in that level of--
in that level of abstraction,
you're going to have containers.
If you're an organization that's
already familiar with Docker
and you want to run a
fleet of Docker containers
efficiently across
a fleet of machines,
Kubernetes is a
fantastic option.
Now, the next step up when
you get to App Engine,
this is where we start thinking
less about infrastructure,
and we start
specifically thinking
about serverless-style
architectures.
You want to hand us our code
and ask Google to figure out
the most efficient
and cost effective
way to go run that code for you.
And really, that's
what App Engine does.
Again, web
applications and APIs--
you give us the code, we run it.
And then at the top,
if you have a system
where you want to respond
to very specific events--
think WebHooks-- or every time
a file is written into a GCS
bucket, you want to have
a little bit of code that
reacts to that, that's where
Cloud Functions becomes
a perfect bet.
Instead of thinking at the
application or service level,
you're now thinking at the
function and event abstraction.
So this is just kind of the
examples of the various levels
of Compute we have
and where I think
your applications can fit in.
So with that-- you
know, it was a lot
of talking-- let's get into it.
This one is seven
or eight tricks.
I'm going to be honest,
until last night,
I didn't have the
eighth trick working.
So I wasn't sure if I
was going to have eight.
But we'll see, at the
end, if it worked out.
So trick number one, you
can go from your code
to production in
a single command.
That command is
gcloud app deploy.
Now, this is part
of the Cloud SDK.
And this might be something
that we take for granted,
especially if you've
been an App Engine
user for a long time
it's been out there.
But when you think about what
I would normally go through
with a deployment,
I could deploy
to an individual
virtual machine.
I could take these files
and upload the one VM.
But what happens when my
application gets popular
and it needs to scale up?
What happens when,
maybe, there's
trouble in the zone where I've
deployed my virtual machine?
What happens when, you
know, something changes
with the-- there's a problem
with the underlying disk?
A lot of things can go wrong
when we run on one instance.
And if we're just deploying
to a single machine,
we're putting our application,
and potentially, our business,
at risk.
And we need to think about
a lot of these problems.
So when you create a
deployment in App Engine,
we're going to do
a couple of things.
We're going to take your code.
We're going to upload it
to Google Cloud Storage.
We're going to take that.
And you don't need to
understand anything about Docker
to use App Engine.
But under the hood, what
we're actually doing is
we're building your code
along with our runtimes
that we build into a container.
And then that
container gets pushed
to Google Container Registry.
And now it's available
for all of your App Engine
applications.
We set up a Google Cloud load
balancer, which, this is new.
We're now using the
same Cloud load balancer
across all of Google's
infrastructure
is coming in the same path.
And then we're going to
take your application,
and we're going to run it in
three availabilities zones.
Now, the reason
that we do this is
that there may be trouble in an
individual zone at any point.
You know, generally, this
stuff is very stable.
But sometimes things in
individual zones happen.
So what we do is
automatically, out of the box,
configure App Engine to deploy
to three different availability
zones so that even if
we do have a problem,
your application is
going to automatically
rebalance and keep
serving to your customers.
And then within
each of those zones,
they all independently
autoscale.
So as the use of
your application
grows, and as traffic increases,
and as that use contracts
again, we're going to
automatically provision
and release new instances
to serve your application.
So along the way-- so
we just talked mainly
about application instances
and the autoscalers--
there are a bunch
of other things
that we're setting up
out of the box, stuff
that, when you deploy an
app to that individual VM,
you have to think about
at one point or another.
You have to think about logging.
How are you capturing your logs?
Where are you
sending those logs?
Is that log system
going to scale?
Can you query through it
efficiently when you need to?
When you think
about autoscaling,
what do you happen
when you get popular?
Traffic goes up.
Traffic comes back down.
Load balancing, monitoring,
health checking,
configuring SSL, these
are all additional things
that, when you go to set
up a site or a deployment
on your own, you
have to internalize
and you have to think
about instead of building
your application or
focusing on your business.
And they're all things that
we aim to do with App Engine.
So one of the new
things that we have--
that we've had now for
a couple-- actually,
for a couple of months we've
been working on-- or a couple
of years--
is the App Engine
flexible environment.
So originally, App Engine was
available in Go or Python,
Java, and PHP.
And we've now expanded that
to include Node.js, Ruby.
And the big announcement
yesterday, of course,
is .NET going beta on
App Engine as well.
And you can even bring
your own container.
And this is something that
we're going to get a chance
to look at in a little bit.
One of the big changes we were
able to announce yesterday
is all these services that
you can run your own Docker
container, Node,
Ruby, you can do
all of this with a 99.95% SLA.
And that's something
that we're able to offer
because, as of
yesterday, the App Engine
flexible environment is GA.
It's OK, you can clap.
[APPLAUSE]
I need this.
Thank you.
So the first trick
was gcloud app deploy,
getting 99.95% SLA
with a single command
and not having to
think about it.
Let's dig in a little
bit to the second trick.
And this is one of
my favorite ones.
With App Engine, I
can split traffic
between multiple versions
of my application.
So why is this important?
Think about that
deployment we just created.
So we pushed our code.
We got it out there.
We have our multi-zonal release.
We've got many instances.
It's going great.
But now I'm ready to
push a new version.
Well, how do I know that my
new version doesn't have a bug?
How do I know that it isn't
going to bring my app crashing
down when I do it?
What I want to do is I want
to deploy a second version
of my application.
I want to verify it
out-of-band, both with tests,
and I want to go
do manual checks.
And then slowly,
over time, I want
to take just a
little bit of traffic
and start sending it to
that new set of instances.
I want to make sure
that it can scale up
the way I expect it to.
I want to make sure that
things don't come crashing down
when I want to monitor errors.
And then only when
I'm ready, and only
when I'm sure that this
new deployment is good,
I want to transition
100% of my traffic
over to the new
version, and then
eventually, turn
down the old one.
And what this is called
is a no downtime upgrade.
And it's something
that's very difficult
to get right on your own,
but one of the things,
with App Engine, we
make very simple.
Use gcloud app deploy.
You set a traffic split however
you'd like to set it, verify,
and then go to 100%.
And it's really easy to set up.
So another reason
that you might want
to go off and use our
traffic splitting feature
is if you want to do
something like AB testing.
So let's imagine that I have
an application out there.
I'm an online grocer, and
I'm selling fruit to people.
And I'm trying to decide,
which background image
is going to cause my
customers to come into my site
and buy more fruit.
You know, what do they
think is more delicious?
What gets them salivating
and buying things on my site?
Is it apples?
Is it cherries?
Is it lemons?
Or is it the deliciously
pungent durian, you know?
I don't know.
I don't know what's going to
go ahead and get them hungry.
So let's actually--
it's demo time.
Let's figure out how we can
actually go build something
like this on top of App Engine.
So what I've got here is
I have a site that I've
created on App Engine.
It's got a single service.
This single service has
four different versions
of my application,
each ones that I've
deployed with the gcloud
app deploy command.
And you see, I've got the cherry
version, the apple version,
durian, and lemon.
So if I click on "cherry,"
every time I do that,
I'm going to get a cherry.
Looks pretty good.
Makes me a little hungry.
It is lunchtime.
I can click on "apple," and
I'm going to get my apples.
And you get the point.
I can click on
these individually.
And any one at a
time, I can verify,
is going to give me the
fruit that it's named after.
But right now, all of my
customers are getting cherry.
So every time they
come to the site,
they're going to get cherry.
How do I enable a traffic split
to test out my hypothesis?
You know, I'm going
to go with the idea
that I think Apple
is a better fit.
I can select all the versions
of my running application
right now.
I can choose Split traffic.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go ahead and say,
apple's going to get 33%.
Lemon is going to get 33%.
And Durian, we're going
to put that at 1%,
because we're still testing.
I'm still unsure if the durian
is a good choice or not.
And I'm going to go
ahead and save this.
So while this is
saving, the next thing
that we're going to do is we're
going to click on Services.
And we're actually going to
take a look at how this works.
So I have a single service
right now, one service,
many versions under it.
And I'm going to go ahead
and launch this page.
And it looks like, OK, the
first time, I got lemon.
The second time, I got
cherry, and then apple,
and so on and so forth.
So what we can actually do--
the way I've set
up this site is I
want to be able to track this.
You know, maybe
you don't believe
that we're actually doing that
traffic split exactly right.
So let's go here.
And I'm going to go over
to a dashboard that's
actually tracking all of
the hits on this page.
And I see somebody
hitting apple.
I don't know if anyone was
able, actually, to see that URL
or not.
And so this is the point in the
talk where I want everybody--
usually speakers don't
like it when you're
on your phones or laptop.
I'm looking at you,
guy with the laptop.
It wasn't actually you.
Go ahead and get them out.
Get out your phone.
Get out your laptop.
And I want everyone
to try this out.
And we're going to watch it in
real time and see what happens.
So I want everyone to go
to fruit.appengine.io--
so fruit.appengine.io--
and let's see--
we're watching people hit these
pages, coming in real time.
Looks like, right now,
apples are out to lead.
Cherries are catching up.
We're going to keep doing this
until that 1% person manages
to-- oh, who got the durian?
Ah, come on, someone
has to admit to it.
Somebody got the durian.
It was you.
Was it?
Come on up.
Come up on stage.
You are the big winner.
I can't believe it was you
that actually won the durian.
That's amazing.
What I have for you, sir,
is an actual durian--
[LAUGHTER]
--that I got in
Chinatown this morning.
So please do not cut that here.
Take that home.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] .
JUSTIN BECKWITH: That was a lot
heavier than I expected it to,
I'm not going to lie.
Yeah.
Enterprise scenarios
here folks, that's
what we're focusing
on this week.
All right, so that's
one of the ways
that we can use
traffic splitting
to both do safe upgrades
and to make sure
that we have the best version
of our site for A/B testing.
By the way, all those images--
Creative Commons.
Thank you to the very
nice people who made them.
They were beautiful.
So that was trick number
two was traffic splitting.
Let's take a look at
trick number three.
And this is a big one.
As of this week, you can now run
.NET core applications on App
Engine.
And that's because ASP..NET,
on App Engine yesterday,
went beta.
So what that means is that
we have a .NET core runtime.
We've got a full list
of tutorials, samples.
The same runtime you
can use on App Engine,
you can actually pick up and
use it on Container Engine
and run it there as well
inside of a Linux VM.
All the client libraries-- so
the things that use to access
services like Spanner, the
Cloud Vision API, Datastore,
all these services and APIs
that we have out there are now
available via NuGet
packages on .NET.
And finally, some tooling--
all of this is available.
You can learn about it on
cloud.google.com/dotnet.
And it's got all of that
getting started documentation.
The runtimes, the client
libraries, the docs,
all of the stuff that
we're putting out there,
it's all on GitHub.
So you can actually go to
github.com/googlecloudplatform,
search for .NET, and you're
going to find all the source
code that we used to go
build all of this stuff.
And of course, the
part that I want
to take a little
bit of time and look
at that I think is
the most interesting
is the integration directly
into Visual Studio.
So let's take a look
and try that out.
All right, so over here,
I'm running Visual Studio.
This is-- I believe it's 2015.
And I've got a hello world
ASP.NET project up and running.
So I'm going to go ahead and
Alt-Tab over to my web browser.
You can see it's
running on localhost.
And this is your traditional--
for those of you that have done
ASP.NET, you're probably used
to staring at this screen.
It's the traditional file, new
project, hello world template.
And what you can
do, as of now, is
if you go-- if I want
to-- let's say I'm
ready to deploy to App Engine.
I can go to my project file.
I can right-click on that.
And I'm going get a
couple of new options,
but the one that
we're going to try
is Publish hellogcp
to Google Cloud.
Now, at this point, we're
going to give you the option.
We're actually going
to let you choose,
do you want to deploy to App
Engine flexible environment.
Do you want to deploy
to Container Engine?
And we're also going to
be rolling out support
for doing this on Compute
Engine soon as well.
And you can just
pick one of these.
And wherever you want to
deploy, click the button.
Tell us what you want
to name the version.
We automatically
provision one for you.
We're going to automatically
promote so that this
goes straight to prod.
And when it's done, I want it
to go ahead and open the website
and show me the site.
So as this is going
off right now,
we're going to do the build.
It's going to kick off
the deployment process.
And while that happens,
I want to take a look
at a couple of other things.
So now, under Tools, we also
have this Google Cloud Tools,
and we have the Cloud Explorer
and the Account Manager.
Let's check out the
Account Explorer.
This is kind of
my favorite part.
From within-- inside
of Visual Studio,
without having to go to the
Google Developer-- the Cloud
Developer-- console, I can get
a list of all of my App Engine
applications, each version
that's out there running.
You can see I already deployed
this version earlier today.
I can see all of my
Google Compute Engine
virtual machines.
And I have options to
interact with those
and set settings on them.
I have all my Cloud
Storage buckets
and all of my Google
Cloud SQL instances
all right here inside
of Visual Studio.
If you're a .NET developer,
we think this is something
you're really going to love.
So while we're waiting
for this to deploy,
you can see I already have
a version deployed out here.
Let's go ahead and check it
out running on Google Cloud.
So I can right-click and say
Open the Running Service.
And there we have it,
ASP.NET on App Engine.
All right, so trick number three
was running .NET on App Engine.
Let's get into
trick number four.
Trick number four is, I can
customize my operating system
packages.
Now, what does this mean,
and why is it as important?
Traditionally, with
Platform as a Service,
one of the walls
that we've run into
is that you'll get started,
you deploy your hello world,
your hello ASP.NET
web application,
you get up to a certain
point, and you hit a wall.
There's a library you need.
There is a language
you want to use.
There's some part of
the system that you
need to go beyond where, if
you were on a virtual machine,
you could do it.
But because you're in a
Platform as a Service offering,
you get stuck.
Well, we don't think
you should have
to get stuck when that happens.
So what we want
to do is give you
the ability to bring in any
operating system package,
and your Linux virtual machine,
that you want to bring in.
And so as a way to show
this off, what I want to do
is talk about, there's
this application
that I wanted to build.
I wanted to send everybody
home with something.
And as it would turn out, that
would have been a lot of durian
if I'd have chosen that.
So instead, I want to send you
all home with a Twitter card.
And this is a card you
can make on your own.
It's got the Next branding.
Take a picture.
And you can go ahead
and put that on Twitter
if you'd like to.
So let's see what
this looks like.
Let's actually go ahead
and give it a try.
So I'm going to go
ahead to appengine.io.
And what this is going
to do is it's going
to use the webcam inside--
on the web page.
I'm going to give a smile.
All right.
And this is going to go take--
send my picture to App Engine,
use a couple of custom tools,
generate this card.
And then when I'm ready,
I can go tweet it out--
so pretty cool.
So how would I go and
build something like this?
How do I do the
image manipulation?
This is a very classic wall when
you're running up and building
one of these apps.
The way that I was able
to do it on my MacBook
is I just ran brew install
imagemagick, you know?
Done.
It was amazing.
It works on my machine.
Ship it.
And then I went a little
further, and I figured out,
actually, I want
GraphicsMagick, you know,
that sits on top of ImageMagick.
OK, so now I'm building
up a lot of libraries.
Well, it worked locally.
But how do I get
that onto App Engine?
And this is where Docker
comes to the rescue.
And let's actually
check it out and see
how we would go build that.
So here is my local version
of the web application.
This happens to be in
Node.js by the way,
but you could run it in
whatever language you'd like to.
And if you look
down, I'm going to go
find the spot where I'm
grabbing the image that
gets posted to my site.
So it's posting to
this sendpic endpoint.
And then I'm going to
save the file locally.
And then I'm going to go
use the GraphicsMagick npm
module, which has a dependency
on that underlying binary being
installed inside
of my container.
So how do I do this?
Well, what I'm going
to do right now
is go out to the command line.
And I'm going to go ahead into
my Photobooth application.
You can see all
of our files here.
And what I want to do is
I want to grab the Docker
file that App Engine
is using under the hood
to build my system.
Right now, the only thing that
I've had to tell the App Engine
is, here's an app.yaml.
Please use Node.js for me.
But I want to control
the Docker file.
So what I can do now is
I can say gcloud beta app
gen-config --custom.
We're going to tell it
to update my app.yaml.
And now, when I
go back over here,
I'm going to get a
couple of new files.
I'm going to get this Docker
file, which is a file that I
didn't have before.
And it really explains
how we're going
to build your application.
I'm going to use the
base Node.js image--
again, open source on GitHub.
And we're going to go ahead
and install our dependencies.
I happen to use Yarn.
If you're a Node.js
person, then you
know it's kind of the
hipster thing to do now.
So what we would
need to do now is
we need to add the
part of code that's
going to install our
client libraries.
So let's give this a shot.
So what I'm going to have to
say RUN apt-get install -y--
ooh, I almost messed it up--
apt-get update-- update--
and then apt-get install -y -q
imagemagick and graphicsmagick.
Save, and that's it.
When you take and
gcloud app deploy this,
because there's this Docker
file in my current working
directory, it's going
to take that as a cue.
And instead of
using the container
that we were going
to pop out, it's
going to use the base container
and add our stuff on top of it.
And then if I want to
try this out locally,
I really even need anything
quite like a local emulator.
I can actually just use the
standard Docker toolchain
to test this out and know
that it's going to work.
So I can go off and do
my docker build -t myapp.
And I'm going to end up
with a container that
has everything I
need, at which point,
I can go ahead
and docker run it.
When I'm ready to go
to production again,
gcloud app deploy.
And it's going to
be off to the races.
So again, we were able to
just use gcloud app deploy.
We were able to build
our own Docker container.
All we had to do was add
a little bit of logic
to install ImageMagick
and GraphicsMagick.
And again, this is one of
those times-- everybody,
get out your phone, or
your laptop, or whatever.
You can go to
card.appengine.io and actually
tweet out the card that
you're generating from this.
And I'm going to go
ahead and do it as well.
I didn't actually tweet out
the last one, so let's do that.
Or here, I'll actually
tweet this out.
So there we go.
Sweet.
Make a good face.
Make it look happy, people.
All right.
So trick number four, we were
able to customize the operating
system packages.
Trick number five, we're
actually going to take,
and we're going to make our
app a little bit better.
So when you look at the
application that I just ran,
it was really a single
App Engine service.
And it was a bit of
a monolith, right?
We had one code base that
was responsible for accepting
the uploads.
It was running image processing.
It was generating new images,
writing things to GCS.
It was sending out links.
You know, this was one
service that was doing a lot.
And you have to
wonder, over time,
what's going to happen
when I scale up?
What if my web process
needs fewer resources
than the parts that's doing
image manipulation, which
is most likely the case, right?
Is my application
going to be scaling
as efficiently as it could be?
What happens when
I'm ready to deploy?
I've introduced more risk.
Every part of my application
is all bound in one thing,
and I can't separate it out.
So instead of just having one
service that's having problems
and deploying one
set of changes,
I have to bring the
whole thing up and put it
all out at the same time.
So the next thing that you can--
trick you can use on App Engine
is building apps that
use microservice-style
architectures.
So the way this works
is, on App Engine,
every time I gcloud
app deploy, I
can choose to build
another service.
And I can keep adding
more and more of these
to construct my application.
These services can talk to each
other directly through HTTP,
or they can use a
worker queue system.
In my case, what I did
is I took the front end,
I separated it out into
a front end process.
It's only responsible
for serving web traffic
and accepting
uploads of the image.
I then created a backend service
with a different autoscaler
and its own set
of instances that
are responsible for
taking images, running it
through GraphicsMagick, and
then sending out the links
so that they get
rendered in the page.
And then I connect the two
using a worker queue pattern.
And I'm using Google
Cloud Pub/Sub.
So by doing this, what I'm
able to do is independently
scale the front end
of my application
from the back end
making sure that I'm only
using the resources that I need
and reducing the
amount of risk I
have when I roll
out new changes.
So to do this, we saw
that file, app.yaml,
which essentially described how
I want App Engine to interpret
the code that we're sending it.
And what I had to tell it
was, the runtime is Node,
the environment is the App
Engine flexible environment,
and the name of my service
is the frontend service.
And I had one of these
for the back end as well.
And then when you're ready, all
you do is gcloud app deploy.
And you can run many of these
within the same project using
the same underlying resources.
But in this example, I used
Node, because at this stage,
JavaScript is the language
I'm the most comfortable with.
What if you don't want to
use Node for your back end?
What if it's a different
team building the back end
than the front end?
What if you want to use Perl?
Well, that happens sometimes.
Sometimes you have an old
piece of code laying around.
Or you have that
guy on your team,
or that girl on your team, who
just needs to do it in Perl.
And on App Engine,
this was another one
of those walls of pahs
that you would run into,
but not anymore.
So the next trick that
you can do on App Engine--
number five was
microservice-style
architectures.
Number six is bring your own
language to the platform--
yes, even Perl.
So let's try it.
Let's do it.
All right.
I'm going to go over here.
I'm going to get out of
my Photobooth application.
And I'm going to go into some
demo Perl code that I wrote.
And let's take a look at that.
All right, so here I have a
very simple Perl-based web
application.
It's, I believe, Perl 5.
It's using a web framework
called Mojolicious,
which is fun to say.
And it's essentially just
a very simple web app.
It has a single handler
that's going off
on the root of the
web application.
And it's going to
render a template named
"index" that I give it.
And over here in my
templates directory,
I have template.html.ep.
And it just says,
"Welcome to Perl,"
along with a fancy
green background color.
And then, to make that
work on App Engine,
I really only needed
to add two files.
So one is I had to add
this app.yaml file, which
we've already talked about.
This describes how, to App
Engine-- tells App Engine
how to run the app.
We say, it's a custom runtime.
Don't use Node.js.
Don't use Ruby.
I'm going to tell you how
to go run this application.
We have the environment.
And then, I'm deploying
multiple of these services
within one app, because
we're actually going
to try a few other languages.
And then, the way that
we do a custom runtime
is by providing our
own Docker file.
The exact same way that we
were able to customize Node,
we can use that to
bring our own language.
And so in this case, instead of
using the built in App Engine
base image in Docker,
I'm just going
to use the latest version
of the Perl base image
that's out on Docker hub.
I'm going to install
some dependencies,
so I'm going to use
Perl's package management
system to go install
the Mojolicious library.
I'm going to tell it to
listen on port 8080--
this is a bit of a magic port
on App Engine that says where
your application is
supposed to serve--
add the source files, play
around with permissions,
and then finally, run
the main Perl process.
And that's it.
I can take this, run
gcloud app deploy,
and have a live version
of Perl running on my app.
But let's try it out.
Let's see what actually happens.
So I deployed this, like
most of these, earlier today.
And I'm going to go ahead and
do a gcloud app services list,
give you a little
preview, maybe, of things
that are to come.
We can see, one of them
here is the Perl service.
And just to see this
running out on App Engine,
I can do gcloud app
browse --service perl.
This is a little
convenience command
that's going to go ahead
and open it in the browser.
And so here we have
Perl on App Engine.
[APPLAUSE]
So Perl is fun.
But let's say I have
a little bit more
of an earthbound scenario here.
You know, I'm not dealing
with a legacy system.
Let's say that you're
an iOS developer.
And you've spent all of these
years building up expertise
in iOS applications, tons of
years getting used to, first,
Objective-C. And now you've
dove head first into Swift.
And you want to be
able to take advantage
of all this experience
that you have
building Swift applications
on the client for the iPhone
and use that in building your
backend web applications.
Well, on App Engine, you
can actually do that.
So what I'm going
to try out now is
I have a demo with a
Swift web application.
Again, we're going to run code,
take a little bit of a lap
around the source code,
and see how it works out.
All right.
So in my sources,
I have main.swift.
And this is using the Kitura
web framework on top of Swift.
I'm going to build
a new router object,
create a route for
my health checks,
and then add the
HTTP server, telling
it to listen on port 8080.
Not a whole lot going on
here, very simple app.
All right, so if we
look at the Swift file,
we can see the dependencies
that we're bringing in.
And we're using the
Kitura web framework,
similar to how we were
using Mojolicious on Perl,
or Express on Node, or Rails
on Ruby-- same concept.
And then inside of my
Docker file, even simpler
this time, I'm able
to take and just,
from the base image that's
out there for Swift,
add my source code, do a Swift
build, tell it how to run,
and we're done.
We're running Swift inside
of Docker on our machine.
Let's go ahead and try it out
and see what it looks like.
So gcloud apps services
list we did above.
This time, when I do
gcloud app browse,
I'm going to say service.
And we're going to look
for the one name "swift."
And here we have the hello
world for Swift running up
on App Engine.
So you're able to take the code
that you want, the languages
you want to write in.
For seven of those,
we have them built in.
But if there's a
language that you
need to use that
we don't support,
you can just go into
a Docker container,
five lines in a Docker file.
And pretty much
any language, you
can actually one on
top of App Engine.
And this is what we described.
I can use my own Docker file.
I can take the existing runtimes
we have and take it out.
Now, what's interesting is you
can take those out and actually
even go run them on
Kubernetes or run them in GCE.
The code that you build
between these platforms
is entirely portable.
You can let us
build the container,
or you can build it in
your own infrastructure.
You can build in Jenkins
or in your own CI system,
then do the deployment.
Or we'll do it.
You can publish your container
to Google Container Registry.
And then, as I mentioned,
these are very portable.
So if you look back
at our application,
we did a little bit of what I
like to-- we looked at, said,
it's a monolith.
Make it microservices.
The guy from Google said
microservices are good.
But really, we didn't really
do any performance analysis
to back up the fact that we
had to go do that, right?
So we split it out.
We did a lot of work.
If I wanted to go
do that, we really
haven't asked the question, how
is my application performing,
and how can I go
figure that out.
So let's check out how we can
go analyze the performance
of our apps in production.
I'm going to go over here.
And I'm hoping that some of
you used that Photobooth app.
Because if you didn't, you
didn't generate enough load,
and the demo's going
to go sideways,
and it's just going
to be really bad.
All right, we had
a couple of hits.
So here, I'm on the
App Engine dashboard.
And what we're
taking a look at now
is a whole bunch of metrics
that help us understand
how users are hitting our app.
This is actually
the Photobooth app
that we were just using,
where we took the picture
and it generated
the Twitter card.
And we see we had a little
bit of a traffic spike.
And we got up to a total
of 10 requests there.
So, eh, 10-- I'll take it.
But what are some of the other
metrics that we can dig into?
I can take a look at
the average latency.
And I can see how the latency
breaks down from my requests
at the 50th, 95th,
the 99th percentile.
I can dig in and take a
look at my CPU utilization
and understand how
that's been acting.
If I go down into
the Instances tab,
I can see the current
list of machine instances
we're running.
And I can even get really
deep, detailed information
about how the
autoscaler is behaving.
Here we can see, I'm sitting
at two machine-type instances.
We can take a look
at our utilization.
If that utilization dips
up over the green line,
you can see it scaled
up there for a second.
So I can even dig
deep and understand
how CPU utilization leads to me
autoscaling my application up
or down.
So that wasn't a lot.
We didn't really have
to do much there, right?
Like, I was using ImageMagick.
What did we have, like
10 requests at the peak?
You know, that's
not a lot of QPS.
What if we wanted to
kick this up a notch?
What if I didn't want
to do images, you know?
What could I do to peg
the CPU a little bit more?
Maybe I want to do video.
So let's give that a shot and
see what it might look like.
So last time, we did
a static screen shot.
This time I'm going to go to--
I actually don't
remember the URL.
The other one was "card."
Yeah, it wasn't
video, it was GIF.
That's what it is.
We're going to generate a GIF--
gif.appengine.io.
And this one, instead
of just taking an image,
it's going to record a video.
And the whole time,
I'm going to talk.
I'm going to dance.
It's going to be awesome.
Recording a video on stage--
recording a video while
recording a video.
And then, what we're
going to do is upload
that video from the browser,
send it to an application
that I have running.
And then when it generates
the card, instead
of building a static
image, what I want it to do
is go build something
that's live.
And there we go.
And so I'm going to take
this and post it to Twitter.
[APPLAUSE]
Ah, thank you.
I was inspired by a
movie about wizards
where everything they read
had moving pictures on it.
And I wanted that for myself.
So you can go to
gif.appengine.io,
generate one of
these for yourself,
and tweet it out
if you'd like to.
But let's talk about how
I actually built that
and why this might put
a strain on my system.
So to build this, I
chose to use FFmpeg,
which is kind of
like the Swiss army
knife of video editing
in the same way
that ImageMagick
is the Swiss army
knife for image processing.
But as you could imagine,
when I started playing around
with that, especially if any
of you are trying it right now,
FFmpeg takes a fair
bit of CPU cycles.
This is video processing.
It tends to be very
CPU-intensive work.
So that leads us to trick number
seven of what you can build
on App Engine, which is, you
can actually-- because it's
so CPU-intensive, I want
to customize the underlying
hardware.
And this is a new
thing that you can
do on top of App Engine
in GA as of this week.
To do that, we're
taking advantage
of Google Compute Engine's
custom machine type feature.
Now, what this lets
us do is actually
size our instances not based
on a pre-canned set of machine
types, but size our
instance completely tailored
to our needs.
So right now, we give you
a preset version of CPU,
memory, and disk that seems
to work for most people.
But for my image-- or for my
video processing application,
what I really needed is, I
didn't need as much memory.
When it came to disk, I wasn't
storing anything locally.
I was using Google
Cloud Storage.
So I didn't need much disk.
When it came to CPU,
I needed a lot of CPU
if we were going to
handle a couple of people
in a room for this talk.
And to specify that,
all you need to do
is, inside of that app.yaml
file where you're telling us
the rest of how to build
your app, just tell us,
I need a lot of CPU, I need
a little bit of memory.
And that's it.
You can customize
the hardware inside
of your machine completely
based on the needs
of your application.
So let's give it a try.
And if you want to give
it-- we already did this,
but if you want
to give it a try,
you can go out to
gif.appengine.io.
We can see if we can get
it to scale up at the end,
get it to scale all the way up.
And at the end, we can
take a look at the stats.
You have to prime
some statistics for me
for the dashboard.
All right, so we're getting
towards the end now,
and we've got seven tricks.
Our last one was customizing
the underlying hardware.
It was 7 or 8.
We got the last one to work.
I called on an old
demo from last year,
actually, to get
this put together.
But if you look back
through our application--
I think I've used this
slide a couple of times--
we had a pretty simple app.
But you know, it was a pretty
trivial app that we just built,
right?
There were two App Engine
services, one Pub/Sub thing
in the middle.
In production, our
apps rarely end up
actually looking like that.
This is kind of a
contrived example.
A more classic example of
what you're going to go build
is something that looks
like this, you know?
We're going to have front ends.
We're going to have back ends.
We're going to have the queues.
We're going to have APIs that
we're taking advantage of.
We're going to have
scalable file storage.
We're going to have databases.
We're going to have
managed databases.
virtual machines that
run that old piece of software
that we couldn't port.
You know, there are all
kinds of different pieces
in a real production service,
along with duct tape,
and baling wire, and
love, that it takes
to keep it running over time.
So to do this, one of the
best parts about App Engine
is that you have access
to all of the APIs
that are available
inside of Google Cloud.
Spanner, we announced,
Cloud Machine Learning,
the Video Intelligence
API, Pub/Sub, BigQuery,
Vision API-- there's
a big, long list
of all the different things.
These are now all
at your fingertips
and simple to use from within
of your App Engine application.
You don't just have to use
the services that come out
of the box with App Engine.
It's all of GCP.
GCP is the new
Platform as a Service.
So to do that on
Node.js, all I had to do
was npm install
google-cloud, and we
had an npm module that had
access to all those services.
Of course, if you're
in Python, pip.
If you're in Ruby, gem.
And I kept going with this,
but it was too many slides,
you know?
It's available on all
of those seven languages
that we talked about earlier.
And you use this API,
let's say that I wanted
to do something very simple.
Let's say that I just wanted
to be able to look at a picture
and figure out what's
in that picture--
traditionally, one of
those problems that
take an army of
computer scientists
eight years to solve.
Well, with Google Cloud, on App
Engine, using the Vision API,
I can do it in four
lines of code--
well, four lines of JavaScript.
I can do it in four
lines of JavaScript.
We just bring in the
library, detect the labels.
And then we can find out, is
it a dog, a canine, a poodle.
But you don't have to
take my word for it.
We're going to try it out.
So with access to these
machine learning APIs,
all this technology
that we've built up
at Google over the
last two decades,
all the intelligence, all
the stuff in Google Photos,
mail, inbox--
you know, amazing technology
now at our fingertips--
we could actually go off, and
we could change the world if we
wanted to with this stuff.
I used it to build
an app about my cat.
So let's see what
that looks like.
So I'm going to go to
cloudcats.appspot.com.
And what I wanted
to find out is I
wanted to find out if people
found dogs or cats to be
the cutest of animals.
And to do that, I decided
to use the Cloud Vision API.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to go off and read a
bunch of data from Reddit,
r/aww to be specific.
This is all real time.
You can go and check
it out if you want to.
And we're going to figure
out, are there more
pictures of dogs or cats
on the aww subreddit.
So let's give it a shot.
OK, so we're downloading
each of these images.
This is a front end process.
It has a back end.
Communication is
through Pub/Sub.
And it's using the Video API.
We've got our first response.
And it looks like we've got
cats out to an early lead,
but the dogs are catching up.
Oh, there are a lot
more puppies in this one
than there usually
are, so that's good.
We've got sleepy kitty.
We've got a little bit
of duplication going on,
but that's OK.
I think the dogs are
back out to a lead.
We have a-- I think
that's a Yoda cat.
That's awesome.
We've got Jedi cat,
dog in sunglasses.
And this is going to
go on for a while.
And at the end of
this, we're going
to be able to use
the Cloud Vision
API to break up
and split out all
of these different
characteristics.
You know, all the
chaos in these images,
it can tell us dog,
cat, neither, or both.
Cat with pancakes--
that is amazing.
All right.
And let's see, I have to wait
until it gets to the end.
I have to know if the
cats or the dogs win.
Too much anticipation.
All right, I'm just going
to let it keep on chugging,
and we'll come back
to this in a second.
So what did we learn today?
The big things that I want
you to come away with,
and I'm hoping that you came
away with, from this talk
is that we really want you to
be able to focus on your code.
You know, as
developers, we really
have to be thinking of our
customers all the time.
We have to be focusing on
doing what's best for them,
building our applications,
focusing on our business.
Shouldn't have to focus
on infrastructure.
And that's one of the
goals, ultimately,
that we have with App Engine.
I want you to be able to focus
not only just on your code,
but any code.
It shouldn't be limited
to the seven languages
that we support.
We want you to be able
to bring in anything.
Bring in your Perl.
Bring your Swift.
Bring your Elixir,
whatever you need
to run your application inside
of the cloud to solve problems
for your customers.
We want you to be able
to break beyond PaaS.
So a lot of the limits
that you traditionally
think of when you run into a
Platform as a Service offering,
you shouldn't have
to put up with it.
There should be ways to
use custom amounts of CPU,
your own languages,
bring your own container.
And lastly, we want to be
able to liberate intelligence.
So we have access, now, to
things like the Speech API,
the Video API, the Vision API.
You can now use these, fold
them into your applications,
and use them to help solve real
problems for your customers.
All the stuff that we did
today, as I mentioned,
is up on GitHub.
There's a bunch more
information at these links
you have over here.
If you have questions
for us, if you ever
want talk to the App Engine
team, we're always available.
We're always on our Slack room.
You can go here, to
gcp-slack.appspot.com to sign
up for that.
And we're happy to answer
questions for you any time.
And thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]